what i want to do in this video is step
through the insertion sort function that
we wrote in the last video but before i
do that i actually want to just focus on
one part of it because i realized that i
used something that you probably don't
recognize because we haven't used it
before i used i used the keyword right
over here i used break and you might
guess what break means but i'll now
explain explicitly what break means is
break out of the smallest loop that you
were doing so we were we were taking our
item and we kept comparing it to the
thing to the left of it or taking value
and comparing things to the left of it
and as soon as we found value not being
less than the thing to the left of it we
said hey we're done we don't have to
keep going to the left and in that
situation i want to break the loop so
we're breaking this while loop and then
we just continue in our next iteration
of this for loop over here so that's
what break did now that out of the way
let's actually step through this program
on a simple example so let's say that
someone calls
well let's just define let's just define
a to be equal to let me think of a
fairly simple list 2
2 1
i don't know
2 2132
i think is a good list over there and
let's assume that we are calling
insertion sort
insertion
sort
insertion sort on a
let's think about what's going to happen
well the first thing of course that list
let's keep track of all of the variables
here so one of so list is right from the
get go going to refer to
3 2.
that's the list right from the get-go
and then we enter into the function for
index in range and let's parse this part
right over here so what is len
of the list so len
of
our list is the same thing as len of two
one
three two and this is just really the
number of elements len is short for
length not that much shorter but len of
this is just going to be one two three
four it's going to be equal to four
elements so this right over here is
going to be four and then the call
range
range between one and len of list is
four
this will return the list this will
return the list starting at one up two
but not including four one
two three
and so these are the indices we wanna
use because this the first index is this
right over here second index is this
right over here and the third index is
that over here remember this is the
zeroth index so index is going to keep
incrementing between these two it's
going to be one first then three then
two so let's just
let me just create our variable index
that's going to be whose scope is inside
of the for loop so let's say we have
index
index is going to start off being the
first item the first item in this list
right here the list generated by range 1
comma len of list so index is going to
start off being 1
and then over here we say value is equal
to the index element in list so let me
define our variable
value value so what is list of
one
what is so what is the first element in
the list is the zeroth element this is
the first element so we're looking at
this right over here this is it is the
first element so that's fair enough and
then we define i to be index minus one
so let me put i over here
and do a new color so now let's do i it
is index minus one index is one so index
minus one is zero so it's the index of
the item to the left of
value so that is going to be zero this
index is one this is zero
and then we're saying while i is greater
than or equal to zero do all of this
business over here and the first thing
that we do over here is we compare value
we compare value to the object that is
at
the ith element in the list so let me
write that over here so list
list
at i so that is going to be the 0th
element in the list that is 2 that is 2.
so we're comparing value we're comparing
1. we're saying if one is less than the
ith element in list if one is less than
two then do this well one is definitely
less than two we're essentially taking
one and comparing it to the thing to the
left i'm saying hey it's less than that
so it's less than that so let's let's
shift this this two to the right and
let's shift one to the left
and so we go into here we say list i
plus one so what's i plus one i plus one
is one
so this is list of one so this slot
right over here
so this
in yellow that i just underlined that's
this slot right over here i is zero i
plus one is one so the i the first item
or the first slot is this slot right
over here let's replace it with whatever
is at
list
whatever is in the ith element or
whatever is the in the zero slot i guess
i should call it so let's replace it
with this two right let me make it clear
and this time around this is two and
this is the slot where the one was so
we're gonna put this we're gonna replace
that with two and then in the place
where the 2 was we're going to replace
it with value and remember value was set
to 1.
so value is set to 1. and so our list
now looks like 1 2
3 2. and hopefully this looks familiar
if you remember when we first described
the insertion sort algorithm so we go
through there and we don't and then we
and now we want to decrement i we say
whatever i was it's one we subtract one
so now it's zero so the new value for i
is zero the new value for i is zero
actually no no sorry whatever i was i
was zero i was zero you subtract one
from that and now i is going to be
negative one so now i is going to be
i is now going to be negative one and
then we go to the while loop it says
while i is greater than or equal to zero
well i is now negative one so the while
loop no longer applies this will return
false i is not greater than or equal to
0. so it won't perform any of this
anymore and so we'll now go to the next
iteration of the for loop
and so now let's go to the and
essentially what's what's that
signifying is that we were done with
that element we compared all the way to
everything to the left of it and it
found its place or it just found its
place in general
now let's go to the first next iteration
of the for loop now index is going to be
the next element
now index instead of being one is going
to be the next element in the list
generated by this expression here so
index is now going to be two
and now
list value is what's ever at the second
index so it's this item right over here
notice we were at the second to the left
now we're the
or we were at the first to the left or
one right to the left of it now we're
one space more to the right so value now
is going to be three
values now it's going to three i is
going to be index minus one index is two
two minus one is two minus one is one
so this is this is now one
this is now one
and we say while i is greater than or
equal to zero well it's clearly greater
than or z equals
now greater than or equal to zero now
say if value is less than list the
eighth element in list so the value is
three and is that less than well what's
at list i is no longer two
so what's in the first element well
actually it is still a two so it is
still a two
so if we look at the first element list
the first the eighth element in list i
is one
zero one it is still two so i actually
didn't have to cross that out it is
still going to be it is still two right
over there
and so is
if three is less than 2 do this well 3
isn't less than 2 so you're going to do
the else clause and you're just going to
break out of this while loop and that
made sense because you said look we
compared 3 immediately to the thing
right before it to the left of it we say
hey 3 is in the right place 3 is greater
than 2 it's not less than 2. so i'm not
going to do all the shifting business i
don't have to shift 2 to the right and 3
to the left and then look at the next
item i know that everything to the left
of 3 is already sorted so 3 is not less
than 2 it's definitely not going to be
less than anything to the left of it and
so we're done we leave it the way it is
and so then we break out and then we go
to the next iteration of the for loop so
now index is going to be the next item
here it is now going to be equal to 3
the next item in this list generated by
this expression so it's now going to be
index is now going to be 3
value is
now going to be
is now going to be 0 1 2 three value is
now going to be this item right over
here
that is going to be value because our
index is now three so our val it our
value is now two let me cross these guys
out
let me save some space
value is now 2
and now
and now i is 2
i is oh let me i is index minus 1. so 3
minus 1. so that is 2. so i is now going
to be 2 and the object that is at
list at the at the second element of the
list 0 1 2 is now going to be is now
going to be 3. and so the first thing we
do while i is greater than or equal to 0
well i is clearly greater than or equal
to 0 it's 2 right now
if
value if 2 is less than what the i the i
what's in the eighth slot of list so 2
is less than 3. so we do perform this
right over here and so what we do is
whatever is at list of i plus one so
list of i plus one i is two i plus one
is three so whatever is at this slot
which is the third slot where the two
was replace it with whatever's to the
left of it so replace it with the three
so we're going to replace this with the
three and the next element take whatever
was
that that slot to the left where i is
and replace it and replace it with and
replace it with value and replace it
with value so then we replaced it with
value so this thing is now going to be a
2 again
and so and then we and now we decrement
i again so now i is equal to one and we
go through the while loop again i is
clearly greater than or equal to zero it
is one
value is still two remember two is what
we're comparing in while we go through
this
through this while loop but we're
comparing to each of the items to the
left if 2 is less than whatever's at the
ith slot in the list so the first slot
in the list is a 2. well 2 is equal to
that but it's not less than that so we
don't have to do anything more the thing
is sorted 2 is in the right place if
it's if it's equal to the thing to the
left of it we don't have to shift
anything and that means it's at least
equal or greater than everything to the
left of that since everything is shorted
everything is sorted already so then
we're done if since 2 is not less than 2
we break out and we break out in the for
loop it says okay let me see if there's
anything left left in this list to apply
index to there isn't we've used
everything in that list and so we break
out of the for loop and we're done and
the list should be sorted and we see
right here the list is sorted our final
sorted list is
one two
two
and three